[Music]
all right so as Joe Biden's uh
disastrous trip through the Middle East
is continuing and as he prepares to meet
with the Saudi Crown Prince in the
coming days to beg for oil and get them
to sign off on his idiotic Iranian deal
the White House has been silent they
won't say whether or not Joe will
address the murder of journalist Jamal
khashoggi and the multitude of other
human rights atrocities that occur in
Saudi Arabia remember job blamed all of
this the murder on the Saudi Crown
Prince before promising during the 2020
campaign to make the country a quote
Pariah nation and here's your chance Joe
you're going to follow through or is
this just another one of those endless
broken promises khashoggi's Widow broker
silence in an emotional interview with
our very own bill hemmer earlier today
take a look if you could be there
what would you tell MBS
I will tell him your regret if you know
the truth about Jamal
and anyone involved in his crime they
will regret
now instead of committing to discussing
the murder with the Saudi Crown Prince
Joe had this to say
I will bring up I always bring up human
rights I always bring up human rights
but my position on khashoggi has been so
clear if anyone doesn't understand it in
Saudi Arabia and or else then they
haven't been around for a while
so Joe you're going to hold him
accountable for the murder of khashoggi
or not are you there to beg for oil or
not what about their treatment of gays
and lesbians so what about their
treatment of women some people are put
to death punished in a number of
gruesome ways in some cases just for
being gay and what about their
oppressive laws against women weren't
even allowed to drive until 2018 or
obtain their own passport until 2019 and
it's not just Saudi Arabia Biden is
doing business with he's doubling down
on this idiocy of Reviving the Iranian
nuclear deal now rans the world number
one state sponsor a terror they boasts
of similar oppressive laws against women
gay people including the death penalty
if you're gay ask yourself where are all
the radical human right activists all
the woke people in America uh that are
Democrats how come they're not upset
that Joe is doing business with these
countries here with reaction human
rights attorney executive director of
the law fair our project Brooke
Goldstein and Fox News contributor Tammy
Bruce Tammy in a way I guess you know
I'm I'm the one standing up for human
rights I always have I would want
nothing to do with any of these
countries I don't want their money I
don't want their oil I don't even
they're hostile regimes that have
atrocious uh human rights records
they do and you laid it out perfectly
many have noted that at the changes the
small changes when it comes to women's
rights in the Kingdom were really made
for a PR effect that it is still very
difficult in the Kingdom in Saudi Arabia
the uh homosexuality is dictated by the
criminal code which is dictated by
Sharia law and and we've recent
executions of homosexuals there as well
I mean it is horrendous and it's it's a
protected environment in that they want
to show something outside to foreign
countries while it is still repressive
and horribly so internally but this is
more of a story with what you outlined
regarding Joe Biden with Biden
everything is transactional I believe
that he meant that about khashoggi but
now look at what he's willing to do in
order to keep America weak he is willing
to go to a place that is known to be a
horrific abuser of Human Rights because
his priority is to keep his own own
country as weak as possible that speaks
to the nature of Joe Biden in a way that
I think should shock the conscience of
everyone watching this program no matter
who you are we believe in human rights
because we're America we're not perfect
but when we talk about it when we learn
about it when we care about it's because
we mean it with Joe Biden and the
Democrats and perhaps The Establishment
in general this is transactional he now
wants something from Saudi Arabia
Venezuela even Russia China because it
suits his purpose of keeping America in
trouble and that is where we're at right
now it's a horrible place and he's now
going to stand next to uh this horrible
dynamic in in Saudi Arabia because it
suits him
Brooke where all the woke leftists in
this country we're all the liberal
activists human right activists in this
country
um because their silence is deafening
and Joe is only doing it to appease the
climate alarmist religious cult that
believes it's okay to import oil but not
produce it domestically
you know you're absolutely right we are
faced now with the situation where the
president of the United States has to
embarrass himself because of his own
policies he had to do a 180 degree turn
where he used to be calling Saudi Arabia
a pariah State saying quote they have to
pay the price for being bad and now he's
going over there begging for oil because
it is his administration that refuses to
make America energy independent and it's
this dual face two-faced hypocritical
nature diplomacy that really you know
pervades uh what's happening in the
Middle East on the one hand you have our
Ally Israel he's over there signing
Jerusalem declarations declaring that
we're going to do everything we can to
prevent Iran from having a nuclear
weapon and then at the same time turning
around pushing for the Iran deal
reinstating 200 million dollars worth of
funding for the Palestinian Authority
and for Hamas a terrorist group in Gaza
allowing the pay for slave program to
continue where American taxpayer dollars
are going to pay terrorists who murder
often Americans as well who are in
Israel so the hypocrisy is why we are
losing face on a daily basis in the
Middle East and I think it's really
important to add one thing there is such
an outrage over what happened with
khashoggi and it's absolutely terrible
but where is the outrage when American
citizens are killed by Palestinian
terrorists and the Biden Administration
does absolutely nothing continues to
allow American taxpayer dollars to fund
this Terror Administration Brooke thank
you Tom Tammy as always thank you
straight ahead why is the left continue
to encourage incivility against our own
Supreme Court Justices do any have the
courage to stand up and condemn these
threats wait until you see what happens
when Senator Elizabeth Warren was asked
about it that tape is next
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else